Traductor: Tatiana Shlyk
Revisor: Elena Crescia
¿Alguna vez les pasó
de sentir que tenían la posibilidad
de multiplicar su dinero
sin necesidad de trabajar?
Bueno, a mi sí.
Y fue justo en un casino.
Empecé a jugar un juego que se llama Keno
que es muy parecido a la lotería.
En el Keno uno tiene la posibilidad
de ir comprando apuestas adicionales
y de esa forma ir manteniéndose
dentro del juego.
En este juego,
yo al principio no estaba muy enganchado,
pero después de un par de jugadas
en las que casi gané,
me di cuenta que esa noche
podía llegar a ganar.
Así que, empecé a apostar
y fui doblando la apuesta una vez,
dos veces, un par más.
Al principio fue divertido, fue excitante
porque veía cómo
con cada apuesta adicional
me iba acercando
a la posibilidad de ganar el premio.
Cada vez estaba más seguro
de que iba a ganar esa noche
Si yo dejaba de apostar,
todo lo que había hecho hasta ese momento
lo tenía que dar por perdido.
Seguí apostando,
pero un par de jugadas más tarde
llegó el problema inevitable:
me quedé sin dinero.
Así que no tenía muchas opciones,
tuve que pedir prestado.
Por suerte había ido
con algunos amigos al casino,
así que empecé a pedirles ayuda
para hacer un par de apuestas adicionales
y eso funcionó bien.
Me seguí acercando al premio,
estaba convencido que iba a ganar,
era una cuestión de tiempo.
Inevitablemente, el mismo problema.
Por suerte tenía un teléfono,
así que si,
la verdad que a mitad de la noche
empecé a despertar gente
para pedirle prestado dinero por teléfono.
Yo estaba convencido de que iba a ganar
así que no era tanto problema.
La verdad que después de tanto esfuerzo,
esa terminó siendo una noche inolvidable.
No gané, deje mi cuenta bancaria en cero,
deudas con un montón de amigos
y me quedé con un sabor amargo
que veinte años después
no consigo olvidar.
Ahora, hace ya más de diez años
que sigo visitando casinos
pero por diferentes motivos.
Me dedico a desarrollar
juegos para casinos.
Y cada persona nueva que conozco
me hace siempre la misma pregunta.
Así que les voy a contar la respuesta,
les voy a contar cómo ganar en el casino.
Pero lo primero lo que tenemos que hacer
es entender un poco acerca del jugador.
A los jugadores se los analiza,
se los clasifica
en base de un sin fin de variables.
En este momento vamos a enfocarnos
para simplificar en una sola
que es el riesgo.
Aquí no estamos hablando del riesgo
de quedar colgado en una montaña
o pasar caminando por adelante de un tren.
Estámos hablando de la capacidad
que tiene una persona
para enfrentarse a la posibilidad
de que ocurra un evento negativo.
Cómo cada jugador maneja el riesgo
es una parte muy importante
del perfil del jugador.
Imagínense,
es muy diferente, cuando un jugador
está apostando a un número
de entre treinta y siete
que cuando lo hace a un color de entre dos.
Por ejemplo,
¿qué es lo que preferirian ustedes,
tener una ganancia muy pequeña
pero muy seguida
o, por ejemplo,
tener una ganancia importante
pero muy esporádicamente?
Bueno, eso es lo que nos define
como jugadores.
Podemos encontrar al jugador
que apuesta prácticamente
desinteresadamente,
de manera desordenada.
Tenemos al jugador que lo hace siguiendo
una estrategia, completamente metódico
o tenemos al jugador totalmente osado
que apuesta como si mañana
se acabara el mundo.
Otro de los temas claves
que tenemos que analizar
para que yo les pueda contar
cómo ganar en el casino,
es acerca de los juegos.
Cada vez que nosotros jugamos a un juego,
estamos aceptando sus reglas,
estamos aceptando su funcionamiento,
estamos sumergiéndonos
en la realidad que nos propone.
Entonces, eso es lo que nos permite
convertirnos en un corredor de carreras,
convertirnos en un soldado
en otro planeta,
convertirnos en el mejor jugador de fútbol
aunque sea por unos minutos
o perfectamente tener una hermosa familia
de clavijas en el juego de la vida.
Para que yo les pueda contar
cómo ganar en el casino,
es también muy importante
conocer el negocio.
Seguramente,
más de una vez escucharon hablar
o escucharon nombrar la frase
"La casa siempre gana".
Bueno,
es cierto.
En definitiva no existe una organización
sustentable en el tiempo
que pueda persistir
si no tiene una ganancia.
Todos los juegos de casino
donde uno apuesta contra la banca
están diseñados matemáticamente
desde su concepción
para dejar un margen,
el margen de la casa.
La matemática de los juegos del casino
de todas formas
permite que los jugadores tengan
una ganancia importante en el corto plazo
o una pérdida,
pero garantizándole al casino
que en el largo plazo
siempre conserven ese margen.
Yo les voy a contar ahora
cómo ganar en el casino.
Apostar es un tema muy serio
porque depende de nuestras percepciones,
depende de como nosotros recibimos
lo que ocurre en el juego.
Por ejemplo,
en la ruleta,
generalmente en la mayoría de los casinos
podemos ver un tablero electrónico
que muestra las últimas 15 jugadas
donde nos muestra
qué fue lo que pasó las últimas veces
que se hizo un sorteo.
¿Para qué sirve esto?
Porque los casinos vieron
que los jugadores
utilizan esos datos
para considerarlos información
y tomar decisiones en base a eso.
Ahora bien,
dado que se trata de sorteos
completamente independientes,
esos datos no sirven
absolutamente de nada.
Entonces,
el problema es que a nuestra cabeza
le cuesta entenderlo.
La manera en que nosotros
manejamos eso
define el perfil del jugador.
Apostar es un tema muy serio
porque justamente estas percepciones
pueden hacernos creer cosas
que realmente no son lo que parecen.
La ludopatía es una enfermedad
y debe tratarse como tal.
Cada vez que nosotros jugamos,
tenemos que hacerlo a conciencia,
tenemos que hacerlo responsablemente,
tenemos que hacerlo
sabiendo que estamos participando
de este engaño que es el juego
y tenemos que elegir hacer eso
de la misma manera
que cuando vamos a ver una película
de ciencia ficción
o cuando participamos
de un truco de magia.
Ir al casino
o ir a tomar el té, no tendría que tener
una connotación diferente
si nosotros hacemos las cosas
con responsabilidad,
si nosotros tomamos las elecciones
de este tipo de elecciones
de manera consciente.
Para poder contarles
cómo ganar en el casino,
creo que a esta altura
ya todos deben haber
entendido perfectamente bien
que no hay una manera mágica
de convertirnos en millonarios.
Salvo que tengamos
el almanaque deportivo de McFly.
Lo más importante acá,
que es mucho más profundo y más simple,
es que nosotros cada vez que jugamos,
lo hagamos con responsabilidad,
lo hagamos conociendo las reglas del juego
eligiendo jugar a ese juego.
Porque la única manera 100% efectiva de
ganar siempre y cada vez que juguemos
es divirtiéndonos y disfrutando del juego.
Seguramente,
muchos de ustedes se preguntarán
¿Por qué les estoy contando esto?
Porque cada decisión que nosotros tomamos
es una apuesta.
Ahí es donde tenemos que tener atención,
ser un poco más responsables,
estar un poco más conscientes
de reglas del juego.
Con cada una de éstas
elecciones que hacemos,
no como hice yo
aquella noche en el casino,
y entonces poder disfrutar
y divertirnos un poco más.
Por eso,
yo lo que quiero aprovechar
es este momento
para pedirles que la próxima vez
que vayan a tomar una decisión,
se detengan un minuto a pensar
que tipo de jugador son,
pero no en el casino,
en la vida.
¡Muchas gracias!
(Aplausos)